hey everyone it's my bottleless and
welcome to the order flow is a market
analysis for Monday September 18 2017
now markets are continuing their gains
from last week's and the big thing this
week is the FOMC meeting so you know
trading even though we set new highs
today in the equities trading was mostly
muted in the sense that you know we
didn't have a big range there's actually
a very tight range in the SPS so with
that said let's get started here but
first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell we're making the type of investment
decision futures train contain
substantial risk and it's not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all over more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
could be lost not jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results now the
tools I use in this presentation as
always are the order flows trader which
is the volume footprint chart to Delta
scalper and the price rejector now if
you haven't signed up I've got a webinar
tomorrow on the 19th of September with
investor inspiration the sign-up link is
below in the description you should sign
up for it and it's okay if you can't
attend it live there's if you're signup
at least you'll be on the list for the
webinar replay when it's ready so let's
take a look here at the markets there
was some nice trading opportunities
first we'll start in the e-mini x' on
the for range chart okay so this is the
for range chart and you can see coming
into the morning this is 8 o'clock we
were sitting on and we just made a new
low at 2500 our high was 2500 four and a
half so you're coming into the cash open
with a four and a half point range which
you know on Monday on a week that you
have a FOMC meeting it's not surprising
to have kind of a tight range I mean
there was nothing major over the weekend
you know news wise the event wise that
was that's gonna be pushing the market
and you know it's just sort of wait and
see what what the markets gonna give you
as far as trading opportunities you know
at 8 o'clock you had the divergence no
ratio nothing you know nothing to get
too excited about other than just the
divergence a little bit
later you've got the after the cash open
8:32 couple minutes after the cash open
you've got a divergence then the next
bar you've got the ratio again and this
is something to talk about literally in
every video that I do and again it's not
like I'm pulling out esoteric markets
out of thin air you know these are the
same markets that I talk about daily
emini z-- crude oil bonds five years
euro currency soybeans and then what
happens is you start rallying you rally
right up from your lows that's where you
have your divergence all the way up to
the highs and actually make new highs
now on this move up there's really no
reason to be sound and what do you see
is he all aggressive buying you know in
each bar has got imbalances in there
1200 1200 on this one's got you know
imbalance of a twenty seven four twenty
three hundred eight hundred fifteen
hundred three thousand just past the
high another buying imbalance of thirty
nine hundred which is encouraging but
you don't really make any much new any
more new highs you get up to this area
look at this drop-off in aggressive
buying in the Delta you've got you're
coming up here strong Delta's you know
fourteen hundred two thousand four
thousand then you get up here on the
high 73 that's nothing
eighty eight that's nothing and instead
you seen selling start to come in here
you got the Delta scalp or giving you a
sell signal right here you got a strong
negative Delta next bar strong negative
Delta RC when we're looking when I was
looking at this this area up in here I'm
thinking hey we're gonna sell off we're
gonna you know go now and make new lows
and then what happens again next bar
negative Delta so you got - eleven
hundred minus nineteen hundred minus
eleven hundred you know it's not looking
good for this market and what happens
nothing it just proceeds you know this
is nine o'clock here 924 this bar what
happens is you just trade sideways all
the way you know for next three hours
basically you do sell off you know it
just before noon you come down to the
opening price of O two and a quarter
but again you know you're looking at
this and you know at this point I'm
thinking the markets really gonna fall
over and it does and it just goes
sideways it's unfortunate I mean that's
what happens you know sometimes the
market just goes sideways on you there's
nothing I said there's nothing really
you know push this market one way or the
other you're just gonna end up with a
normal trading day as far as the profile
you know comes in you know it's just
it's how it looked
you know port of control is right here
in the middle you know at o2 you know
which is just right around unchanged so
anyway eventually you know a later in
the day you know you you start selling
off okay any signs here yeah I really I
mean you got bullish racial bullish
racial then you got the bearish ratio
put a control pin at the top then again
you know all sound and balances but
again you know earlier you had a lot of
Sun and balances that you know possibly
we could have sold off and we didn't we
just sort of hung around unchanged we do
make the probe down lower come down here
make a new low again you know a nice
selling honestly it's you know five
hundred twelve hundred twenty five
hundred three and a half thousand five
thousand twenty three hundred you hit
this low you got the divergence no ratio
next part you do have the ratio again
you just go sideways on you and it does
probe down into new lows before rallying
up and closing right around unchanged
and then in the evening session this is
where we are but again you know this you
know you could have taken this
unfortunately didn't go anywhere but you
know the real you know I'll say the real
trade I mean you had this trade here
which was a nice trade you know from
getting long from around the old one and
a half area all the way up to the new
highs you do have this cell here with
the Delta scalper giving you a nice sell
around the old four and a quarter four
and a half area which it just you know
didn't really put in much of a move it
just sort of went sideways on you that
you know most likely you want to scratch
I don't think you would have held it
here you know getting short at quarter
after nine yeah you know to say you'd
hold it all the way down into these new
lows that one o'clock is a bit of a
stretch but if you did you know you got
rewarded this trade here this ratio and
divergence failed no reason we buying up
off this low so again you know in
compare it to the the tenor range S&P
chart you know this gives you an idea of
how quiet it was nothing major you have
the divergence on this high here and the
he's on the 10 range but again it didn't
do much of anything I mean you got a
little point of controls migrating lower
which is nice but other than that you
know no reason to be buying off here
it's just a tight range you know if you
could get you know these down the for
range it gave you that move up from the
low to the high but again you're talking
you know move from you know one up to Oh
506 so you know it's a five-point range
a five-point move but on a day where
you're you know at that time when your
range is double o2o6
yeah yes that's the move that you want
right I mean it's literally from your
low up to the high on a day where
there's there's no range basically you
know from double you know ninety nine
and a half up 206 up 205 and a half you
know up somewhere up in here where you
got you know the Delta scalper giving
you a cell so you had one really strong
buy one that didn't work out down here
with the ratio and divergence but you
know what can you do you know not all
trades are gonna be out 100% winners but
again you know this is what you want you
want to move from the low up to the high
all right so this is crude oil this is
the eight range chart
it's November crude and I want to talk
about this because this was interesting
because it's it's almost like two setups
that are up kind of similar in a sense
and you know what I'm gonna talk about
is this high here the swing high now
bear in mind it's it's a double top here
right you earlier he had just hit 50 27
right here now you're hitting 50 27 a
second time
and I get rid of this crosshairs per
second now here this time you have the
delta scalp or kicking in you know the
first time that you hit it you're sort
of running up you got some nice deltas 5
400 500 400 you get up here negative
Delta 400 minus 200 here minus 190 you
don't have the Delta scalp or kicking
off this time you do you have the Delta
scalp or kicking off Delta looks a
little bit different on the way up you
know you hit this area with some small
Delta's 11 1876 so there's some trading
going on in there you know it's equally
distributed and then you get some buying
coming in plus Delta of three five eight
then minus 140 so it's weakening then
you get up here strong negative
- 500 here you got delta of - 267 then
you run down here negative delta of 230
but the bar starts rallying right it's
it's it's a green bar you got the
negative Delta and you got the price
action of the bar you know turning up
right so that tells you there's
potentially some support of mine in here
so while this is bearish these two bars
you're looking at this bar and it's bit
bullish and then your positive Delta in
the next bar next bar positive Delta
strong positive Delta 430 but the bar
turns down so you know it's it's mixed
there's some offers up here obviously
some in decent volume 27 256 200 so you
know I said this area I remember looking
at it thinking we could get a sell-off
you know maybe this market could sell
off you know we do run into this bar
which is a bit bullish you know just
looking at these these volumes some
supportive volumes you know that's an
area that we had just traded in as well
you know and I did see you know if you
just look back you could see there was
some support down in here and in some of
these bars some nice behind so we didn't
pop up but anything like that I like the
fact that we made the new high you know
one-stop you out if you're short on the
Delta scalper though then you you start
popping up making some new highs here so
you know this Delta scalper it stopped
you out you know again you know this
high it's a double double top I don't
like the fact that you traded more
volume the second time you know it's
it's an area that you're going sideways
but I was really looking for a bit of a
sell-off here potentially you know the
one thing that would have I think made
it you know convinced me more is if you
had less volume if you had some sign of
price rejection but still you know I
thought it was worth the shot and I
thought it was worth the shot and you
know the market came right back and just
rallied in my face and we did you know
come up here now you got another high
another new high here and look at the
Delta on this run up 6 33 27 23 on the
high so you got a negative a small
positive Delta and then you got the
Delta scalper coming in here okay so
it's no turning bearish right you say
you just had the delta scalper here that
failed here you got a delta scalper that
failed
this swing high you know that Delta is
it's getting weaker alright it's not a
negative Delta right on the swing high
but it's you know it's kind of a neutral
one it's 23 you could very easily you
know if there's just you know another 25
contracts here on the bid you could have
got sold into you end up with a negative
Delta but you know even at 23 still it's
still weak you know it's still weak it's
not with Delta right don't think just
because it's positive and negative it
means something you know just you don't
look at and say all you got positive
Delta that's bullish well yeah it's
positive Delta we all started to
understand how its forming right and you
know you got to understand that again if
there was just an extra 25 lots on that
bid somewhere anywhere in there on the
bid side you know it would have been a
negative Delta you know I I sort of have
a range you know of an area you know
between you know anywhere between 50 to
2-0 or 25 to zero that it's kind of
neutral right I'm willing to give it a
little bit of leeway because you know
sometimes traders are a little bit late
putting in their bids you can see here
there's strong bids to 74 642 you know
if the trader was just a little bit
quicker and threw a 50 lot here you'd
have a negative Delta you know there's
someone headed and you know later in an
extra 50 contracts here that got sold
and you'd have a minus Delta but anyway
it's still positive but again it's in
that area I have an area where I
consider it you know to be neutral could
go either way
really easily in any way in one trade
you know because sometimes on the market
just moves a he moves fast and you know
people aren't able to get their orders
in in in quick fashion but anyway so
even though it's it's positive 23 it's
still on the small side so you know
again I'm willing to overlook that and
you know take it as Delta is weakening
even though it's a positive Delta Delta
is weakening it's getting lesser it's
you know one from 6:30 or 327 so it lost
300 and then 23 so it you know another
difference of 300 there and then
negative 200 so it's you know it's a
swing from minus 300 Delta here minus
300 and then even from positive 23 to
minus 280 that's also 300 so I know
selling is taking over in this bar you
got minus 800 so
actually about you know almost 600 you
know about 550 contracts so less
aggressive buying by 300 by 300 more
aggressive selling by 300 by 300 you
know over 300 here so you know it's
looking encouraging you know you're
starting to see less aggressive buying
and more aggressive selling come in now
what's the difference between this this
previous bar here
yeah the aggressive buying got last
thing I went from 358 to 140 and then it
just completely flipped here 1 2 minus
509 that is negative 267 you know even
here it's - but you know the one telling
thing in here is is the price action
that you're seeing in the bar is
starting a rally instead of selling off
that's a sign that's probably not going
to work out you got the negative Delta
but price action is telling you
something completely different
in the end this trade didn't work out so
let's see how this one didn't you know
again it's it's kind of similar you got
a swing high you got the Delta scalper
coming in you know this Delta it looks a
little bit more cleaner than this one
but again you know this one is to me is
perfectly fine for a sell this one's a
little bit more methodical gradual - 300
- 300 - 300 - 300 - 300 and then you
know start selling off and just sort of
go sideways in here and then boom you
know again you're trading you know in
this area here at 50 30 and then the
sell off you know and look at this yeah
you got positive Delta positive Delta
green bar green bar okay it's not the
end of the world that that's that by
itself just cuz you got a positive Delta
in a bar and a downtrend doesn't mean
you got to cover your short get out of
the position or get long no not at all
you know you're still getting sorry
excuse me
I join quarter you're still getting you
know negative deltas immediately
afterwards opponent controls up near the
high so even though this markets are
trying to rally its met with selling up
here you know look at these volumes 180
246 300 300 3 3 72 55 so they're strong
offers up here and then now we start
selling off you know all negative deltas
you know from 50 30 all the way down to
new lows again
no reason to be covering it no reason we
buying down here you get down here you
got divergence okay maybe you could take
something off but again there's no
reason to be getting along or anything
like that you get down here and you know
still got a no ratio still got negative
Delta you're starting to see some signs
of life that maybe you know maybe this
low these lows can hold you seeing the
u-turn here here coming in you know one
two three finally you get it you get the
Delta scalper as well coming in here but
again you know these are you know
sketchy you know you got to posit the
negative Delta then positive Delta
positive Delta but red bars you know
it's sort of alternating in here but
again it's nothing really solid that you
can grasp and then in here off the low
you know strong positive Delta Delta
scalper you know you've got again you
had one two three loads that fail or two
loans that just failed on you you know
you got to u-turn u-turn u-turn now you
got the u-turn with the Delta scalper
then in here again you know maybe you're
not convinced you know with even with
this Delta scalper I I probably wouldn't
because I was like I just got a feeling
trade a failed trade you know you got
the same thing here then you got the
Delta scupper okay it's a little bit
encouraging and then when he got here
stacked buying and balance you know 158
128 129 next bar it comes back into that
area it's okay it did hold I'd love to
see a bullish ratio but again 26 is
decent so now I'm thinking okay yeah
maybe this low can hold it's just a
matter of how much of a move can we get
and it starts going up comes in a little
bit sideways then the buying starts
coming back in the aggressive buying you
know you got some small Delta's 96 130
326 but then here boom positive 1035 you
know in balancing balancing balance and
balance and then boom you just you know
you'll really rally up so again you know
if if I wouldn't blame you at all for
you know being hesitant I'm buying this
low because you just had you know a
couple of those that failed here one two
here then you're looking at the same
thing here now you got the Delta scalper
okay it's building up your your
confidence in this trading opportunity
you got a stacked imbalance which again
is very bullish stacking balance off the
low so you know at this point you should
feel a little bit confident you know but
again still you know you just had to
move from fifty thirty all the way down
to 49 70 49 68 on the low now you're
getting a buy signal up here forty nine
ninety that area yeah you can well you
know I don't wanna be chasing this
market but you know there's there's no
shame in being a little hesitant after
just you know these these three signals
failed two signals failed but now the
case is being made that hey you know
what this low can hold for now and what
do you know what happens is you know
you're getting the confirmation and over
the next three bars and again even if
you're getting in at ninety it's okay I
mean yeah ideally you'd love to be
getting in here at 70 but you know it's
not that clear yet
but anyway you know getting in at ninety
is better than not getting in on a move
all the way back up into you know back
up to fifty thirty so that's another you
know another forty you know even we
trade all the way up to forty so that's
you know fifty a good fifty ticks but
you know I'm realistically if you know
if you getting out up here in this area
we start going sideways that's that's
still 20 ticks right sorry 30 ticks
eventually you know we just went
sideways for her spell first spell I
sound like someone from the 1800s
and then you just sort of closed in the
evening session not doing much right now
okay so lastly this is the soybeans
lately I even get a lot of questions
emailed to me about soybeans and I'm
gonna do a video later on some recent
questions that I've been getting that an
order flow and you know one of the
questions I've got actually from a
couple people so it's about soybeans you
know people are you know since the more
I talk about it there's a little bit
more interest and I'm gonna do something
about soybeans I'm gonna sound like a
Salesman for the Board of Trade but
again you know soybeans is a nice
contractor your grains I think follow
order flow beautifully partly because
one it's really a market those markets
are driven by supply and demand you
don't get as much I mean you do have
hedge funds
see participating in the grains but not
to the extent that you got them in you
know these other markets and the retail
participation is a bit lesser it's not
as much as it is in the you know the
financials like crude oil or emini z--
that's not to say that you know there's
no no it's all relative right I mean
volume is a lesson in these grains but
you know the participation is a little
bit less so you know there are there are
if there are day traders in in the
grains but you know not so much as you
know you don't get the big individual
day traders that you would in and say
the crude or emini x' but it's a nice
contract because it follows order flow
beautifully sometimes I mean sometimes
not so nice but you know when it does
it's just beautiful much more beautiful
than I said I think some of these
financial contracts so you know 830 is
the reopen from the night session and
you know just you know just watch what
happens you again you know same things I
talk about again you got the swing high
point of control right up here at the
height of that of the bar you got the
imbalance on the high you come back up
you test it again you got one lot you do
get a little bit of a sell-off and not
the greatest sell-off again you know
from 70 and a half down to 69 and a half
that's that's a full point then it
rallies back up here coming back up into
these highs and you got the imbalance
here you got another imbalance here you
got the Delta surge coming in here as
well
you do take out the highs make a new
high up here come off a little bit no
reason to be selling this high here or
this high right here again you test the
high again but you know no reason to be
selling it yeah I mean just because you
hit a high you know and and you want to
find a reason to sell if there's no
reason to sell I mean what can you do is
no reason to sell then you come back you
know it sounds off here a little bit
just sort of going sideways price
rejecter here then you're making this
move back up towards the high then you
got the Delta scalper coming in here you
had three point controls all lined up
unfortunately right after the trade and
then the market tanks and so you know
it's moving from 1973 you know and a
half and it just sells off quite nice
down to this area down here we got point
of control again you know 115 is you
know I don't wanna clock if you're in
any positions in the beans should be
looking to get out and it closes at once
at 115 so again from 973 and a half down
to 68 and a half again that's a 5 cent
move that that's equivalent to 5 points
in the in the SPS
and then it just sort of goes sideways
here we're a little bit higher in the
evening session but yeah not much going
on right now in the evening session
all right the obligatory nice Delta
scalper charts this is the e if he the
euro currency 5 minute chart
yeah nice buy here and I sell here and
then later in the day a nice buy here
you know even in the evening session
it's much higher right now you said the
sell that didn't work out it just popped
up against you but again yesterday you
had some really nice buys and sells here
in the euro currency on the five-minute
chart but anyway let's go back to your
currency on the 8 range chart see how it
looks you know you got a nice little buy
here the cell doesn't work out the cell
does work out this buy doesn't work out
the cell works out so you got one two
three winners two losers so again you
know if you're just you know risking one
bar
you lose one here you lose one here but
you know this one you're getting one two
three here you're getting nil at one two
three four five six sorry about that
stuff now the air so dry here sorry my
throat is dry but I can you know you
listen you know what you know 10 ticks
here 10 ticks here but you're getting
you know now what is that 30 ticks here
30 ticks there obviously this one a nice
move there even here a nice move into
the clothes so again you know it's all
about risk reward you know you kind of
have some losers no matter what nothing
is a hundred percent in trading but you
know you got to manage it you know
manage the trades and get what you can
get
out of the winners and cut your losers
short and I thanks for watching this
video again I've got a webinar tomorrow
on the 19th with investor inspiration
the link will be in the description to
learn about order flows going to order
flows calm to learn more than Delta
scalper go to Delta scalper calm and
thanks to I hope to see you guys on the
presentation tomorrow so I have a great
day and bye bye